et toi aussi mon amour
[Rires]
chacune de votre côté tu vois comme ça
là tu vois
c'est pas mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fantastique vous voulez pas faire Daniel
tu veux nous faire un petit duo avec
avec
la régie du micro est-ce qu'on peut
avoir du micro les mecs
et je rajoute Dylan qui sera débrouille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rallonge chasse en
[Musique]
il laisse
pas au bout de
la pantalon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe rendez-vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va il va te faire le siffler de la
SNCF je vous fais je vais vous faire la
vraie annonce de départ comment ils font
les chaînes de guerre quand elle s'en va
jeter hein
fais-nous fidèlement
[Applaudissements]
attention au départ je passe du micro je
suis là
[Applaudissements]